how's it going right but it's pretty
packed so here we are again with the
oculus this time we're gonna do a horror
game with the oculus there's two reasons
I don't want to do this the first reason
it's a horror game where the oculus that
should be understandable enough I don't
second reason I get really motion sick
when the games isn't optimized for the
oculus so I'm gonna feel like [ __ ] for
the last 20 minutes and you bros are
gonna love it it is yeah this was a
great idea yeah yeah let's go in there
yeah that's oh that's not creepy at all
yeah I can see all clothes and [ __ ] now
have you
I want to spit that in here you better
okay here we go
here we go
[Applause]
[ __ ] me [ __ ] me why am i doing that
oh I generated right away awesome we're
gonna [ __ ] do this press go away ah
Oh stupid [ __ ] bad guy bad guy bad girl
I'll slap your ass go away go away demon
spawn so uh why I don't not like go this
little light of mine I'm gonna let it
shine on my way she where is she where
are you
oh baby sweet baby cakes on the stake I
don't know what I wonder what I wanna
one minute ah hey walk out walk ahead
hey Tommy Tommy let's have a narrator
wait
you stay away just let a light of mine
I'm gonna let it run yeah run into the
darkness that's a [ __ ] great idea
that's a good idea yeah your your
daughter down pills
you [ __ ] up why I walk in circles
puto ok I'm going wait going breath what
fine I'm fine
this kit product let's get brought it
again it's all brown let that's no
[ __ ] problem at all
oh my god everything it sells [ __ ]
[ __ ] jock fantastic I will [ __ ] you up
with my duck that's right I am a dump
oh just going home what in the heavens
what in the heavens why did I do to
deserve this is the prettiest [ __ ]
[ __ ] ever generator alligator [ __ ] you
stay away
oh you stay away I keep telling you to
stay away let him turn the thing me
laughs I'm cool oh we [ __ ] it up now
bruh Dutch oh we're late we can't go
there Oh
[Applause]
I probably look like a [ __ ] idiot oh
it's working
my ass is hitching I thank heavens never
again what the thou I probably look
[ __ ] half [ __ ] when you turn
around and you hear something and it's
behind it it's absolutely incredible
and she when she was up in my face it
felt like she was [ __ ] up in my face
it was that sounded nice if you like
enjoyed watching or if you want more of
the hits this guy to come wrote today
and I'll see in the next one
Alvarez
[Music]